I really want to move off of this of
[__] okay do your fathers know about
your content or have they disowned you
my dad doesn't
speak because you started doing he found
content he found out he knew he was like
still kind of speaking to me when I did
uh when I was working at the club but uh
I think my cousin found me or something
on the Hub and he found out and he does
not speak to me
so disowned yeah my mother disowned also
or both both double disowned unfortunate
okay
um
so did your father does your father know
about your content and has he disowned
you
know you're ridiculous
okay what about you
about everything I do and have done and
they're both extremely supportive
including the stripping yeah no
seriously like my mom will like ask me
to send her a video she like
yeah
hurray okay
uh my parents do not know but I grew up
in a very conservative Christian
household so that is a conversation then
I prepared myself for the day they do
find out
I mean you're on a podcast
I don't know they still don't know it's
been two and a half years and they some
found out but you know one day they will
and we'll deal with it what do you think
is the uh like in the disown or you
think I don't think they would fully
disown me um but I would definitely get
some Stern conversations Stern
conversation okay
you do a f also yeah
um so father mother do they know yeah
both my parents know and
um my mom like I said was a stripper um
she doesn't particularly like that I do
it but she also will always support me
and always make sure that I still feel
loved and cherished and wants the best
for me regardless
um and my dad he um obviously wasn't
really around too much growing up so I
just kind of like obviously if I had a
stronger male figure out in my life I
probably wouldn't have wouldn't have
even gone there but
um yeah no uh he's also supportive since
being a little bit closer now that I've
grown up more okay uh yeah um my mother
found out
my mom found out and I cut her off
because she's just this very very
conservative Christian with a bunch of
opinions and she does nothing with her
life and my dad was an ex-crackhead so
no I don't talk to either one of my
parents or any of my family because they
all just are lazy so yeah Archduke Franz
Ferdinand
what oh you don't do off okay
okay
thank for the hundred that's a good name
congrats um once you post something on
the Internet it's there forever you
cannot wipe yourself from the internet
to do that is like trying to drain the
ocean okay
well people are really focused on the of
stuff tonight all right Darth Perdition
thank you man
that statistic is deceptive yes single
women from 18 to 35 are the happiest
demo demographic but 35 Plus single
women are the unhappiest demo uh in the
U.S have to look at the whole picture
not just the present
Pleasant stat
thank you man
oh a b check thanks for the 20 gift to
go ahead and they're on more
antidepressants too yeah oh snap well
I'm already on antidepressants so it
makes a difference she's already on well
maybe like maybe you wouldn't be if you
weren't doing only fans
I think if she wasn't making like 70
plus k a month she'd definitely be more
depressed than she is right now
all right we have uh well I'll bring
this one back up Cappadocia he was
asking
um ladies are they real or are they
enhanced betting pool says four of you
are artificially blessed was it worth it
was it an investment that paid off did
your interactions with men change I mean
you noticed
all right
fake fake titties that's a fake titty
comment
um
yeah I'll go
um let's see what was the question again
are they worth it okay mine are fake
yeah whatever okay first off show of
hands
who's got fake titties
you're a bet you're too you're like
gonna get blocked so
boom boom three just three three only
three okay
mine are real uh was it worth it
um within the first week I would say the
benefits that it came with the attention
and everything I was in a relationship
at the time when I got them but after we
broke up yeah the attention was nice it
was cool I didn't really you know I kind
of I could kind of tell that men were
after me you know because I know I had
like big Double D's and stuff but
physically I don't think they're worth
it because I used to get like pleasure
from my you know areolas and I can't
feel a [__] thing and they hurt half
the time how long ago did you get yours
done because it can come 20 20. I only
have feeling in one of mine yeah
I can't complain I have a genuine
question this might be a dumb question
like how does that affect like
breastfeeding later at all yeah it can
it can there's like it's like a
percentage of people cannot breastfeed
but it's like 15 chance yeah some people
are able to some people aren't it's just
biologically oh okay because that's
always what I think of when I think
all right and then TD TD uh you you did
a 50 before but it was blanks I'll read
this but just reminder 199 and up for
read ladies are you comfortable with the
cost oh my God
I feel like these poor girls over okay
uh ladies are you comfortable with the
cost that you will incur with being in
the only fans industry everything has a
cost QQ for the table please explain the
cost is for being a 3fo as you
if you guys want I don't know what the
question is there are you
the cause the cause the cost of being in
the of industry
is that what is that a gifted sense or
what
hold on
oh gifted Sweet Tooth thank you for the
20 gifted memberships appreciate it
I really appreciate all the support guys
especially I'm absolute stress case with
all the technical issues with we've been
experiencing it's very unfortunate
especially after our last stream was
like P
viewership 24 000 now it's just
frustrating to go from like our one of
our most viewed streams and then to face
these technical issues in any case suite
two things for the 20 gifted go ahead
um yes I'm comfortable with the cause
because I knew exactly what the hell I
was signing up for but I feel like
um like how Pearl was saying earlier
which I'm glad this question came up and
she was like you know a lot of girls
will get into this industry and whine
and complain why is no one taking me
seriously why does no one want to marry
me bro I knew that from the beginning I
only really started seriously dating the
moment I was like I can't see so I
started out in porn it's a little
different it's definitely more
intense the kind of hate you get only
fans of me is I've seen it be more
accepted but being in mainstream porn
where you open up Pornhub and you're on
the ads I didn't bother I did not even
bother there's no way because I knew I'm
not saying I knew I was low value or
whatever you guys like to say high value
low value but I knew that like my dating
was gonna be harder but I feel like a
lot of people in only fans are so damned
delusional being like well I am I am a
traditional woman I am a high five no
we're not sorry we just aren't and
that's okay and you'll attract the
people who are okay with what you do but
yeah people want to complain that they
can't
find something be based on their
decision of their line of work
so yeah I'm okay with it as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible